olha onu e vem aqui e falaram sobre a
tarefa difícil que os cozinheiros têm
silva está uma pergunta quando foi a
última vez que vocês tiveram uma
refeição realmente memorável eleição que
vocês sua mãe dela eo ao fantástico
é curioso ver se eu consigo o velho
respostas de cada um de vocês se criarem
eu viro as costas completamente
diferentes
é que integrava us não agradar outros e
provavelmente você já temiam dizer que a
frança que tem nem foi feita no
restaurante com jantar de natal um
almoço de domingo em casa da sogra é que
o que eleva para 11 não agrava pronto e
portanto nós temos alguma dificuldade em
competir primeiro com estas diferenças
que nós temos são memórias que nós temos
no nosso restaurante temos que competir
com isso as emissões que é muito difícil
e depois também porque cada um de vocês
são bastante diferentes dos outros e que
terá uns a outros e portanto esta é ter
essa que nós temos mais difícil competir
com menores memórias de voz bom mas nós
temos as nossas armas enquanto eu tô aí
tivemos as nossas ferramentas para
conseguir criar emoções que vender
momentos que nós fizemos
nós não queremos vender refeições nós
queremos vender momentos criar emoções
portanto temos deslocam cuidado especial
na decoração do espaço no ambiente de
música ambiente e tudo isto faz com que
depois as nossas experiências nos
restaurantes sejam memoráveis sempre a
competir encostar as diferenças que nós
temos que são muito difíceis nós
conseguimos competir com elas
ok
alguns fatores que vêm de fora vocês
trazem o nosso encontro e traseiros com
restaurantes que nós enquanto eles não
conseguimos controlar uma condição
física como dor de cabeça e o jantar ou
almoço nos recebeu tão bem com quem
temos vamos a perna temos um dia em
perceptivos sete anos nos nossos
empregos e portanto tudo isso influencia
o mais influente refeição pode se tornar
um fracasso
se nós levarmos a companhia já vai para
o restaurante
ao contrário vamos uma companhia
fantástica 15 2006 poderá ser uma
refeição memorável
ok bom enquanto cozinheiros sistema para
o outro e nós nossos engenheiros estão
muito escolhidos
nós temos na cozinha cozinha e temos
alguma dificuldade porque nós cozinhamos
com amor e eu fiz a minha formação nós
certamente com 5 100 antes de todo mundo
somos todos diferentes mas a um
denominador comum é ter um de nós é que
nós gostamos de agradar as pessoas
ninguém está nesta profissão ser um
estado degradado as pessoas
nós queremos realmente por uma carga
emocional dos nossos pratos e depois
vender as pessoas e temos uma tarefa
difícil que estamos lá vento estamos nós
nós temos nas cozinhas ok em preparar o
prato como o próprio empregado
melhoramos a parte não podemos deixar de
dizer a nossa vontade era ficar no prato
e usar as pessoas quase da boca a boca
nós estávamos design das coisas
impossíveis reação das pessoas porque
nós gostamos de sentir se conseguimos
com o nosso trabalho e nos cenários
opções bom
fazemos o que podemos fazemos pelo algum
cuidado com 50 menos algum cuidado com
as texturas com as costas tudo isto
ajuda ajuda a vender
temos que criar outros criaram bastante
visual pessoas consigam ter vontade à
vontade de tirar um prato se tirar uma
ou melhoria
um exemplo do pastel de nata é muito
importante porque nós também temos a
função do conselho exportar 15 os nossos
cinco sentidos
o bastão da pesca é um exemplo bom para
mostrar isso todos nós gostamos de
estelionato não é isolada da competição
ao fantástico em 2005 mas é um também um
símbolo nada de especial mas não estamos
estamos bastante visual sentimos um
aroma fantástico também ninguém reclama
estão na faixa de gaza
portugal meu humor no contato e sentir o
morno também especial e depois falando
tudo isso nós conseguimos ouvir o
pessoal nada ser nosso folhada não
tivesse ela diz ah eu não falar connosco
e portanto está um bom exemplo daquilo
que nós enquanto cozinheiros gostamos de
passar um prato mexer com cinco sentidos
que está em ok
bom vamos agora falar um pouco do sabor
porque aquilo que nós somos treinados
nas causas do player é tenso diário o
senhor conseguiu um prato vá parar ao
cliente com o senhor mais do potencial
cível
é isso que nós conhecemos desde críticos
são desvirtuadas a distinguir que nossa
língua nossa música nossa liga tem 44
sentidos diferentes quatro robôs em
frente que nós conseguimos descobrir o
saudava o doce eo amargo e o ácido e
todas as todos os sentidos não pro nosso
cérebro em informações de frente
por exemplo nós após um exercício físico
não é à toa que o nosso cérebro nos
pensa algo dos educadores que estamos a
falar só quem se provar uma coisa margo
nós temos algum mal nos montantes criar
minozzo portanto nós enquanto
cozinheiros temos que conseguir que
esses quatro senhores estejam
equilibrados
essa é nossa terra da gente fica
descobriu que existam quinto senhor
chamado o nome café o homem é o quinto
sabor que nós conseguimos sentir aqui
o princípio do século 21 o vôo japonês
que descobriu que o caldo feito como as
algas combo tinha um sabor tenham
despertar da nossa língua 1113 de frente
do salgado 12
é um seguro próprio técnico tem a ver
com a quebra das campanhas dos 10 das
proteínas
nós temos as causas do problema mas
quando começamos a distribuir pelos
profetas ficamos combinam ácidos e
alguns aminoácidos vezes tem um sabor
especial é que se forneça normalmente o
nome em japonês quer dizer dovizioso
grande com as cem anos a comunidade
científica não convenceu o nome de pneus
que não é verdade
estamos mesmo a junção dos outros touros
não isso não leva a nada
o nome em 2000 e 2001 foi conhecido como
quinto sabor e 9 15 engenheiros ajuda
muita ciência judas muito e nós temos
esse cuidado
nós estamos um pouco o nome nos prados
nós que encontramos um nome em quase
tudo
o nome está por dentro destes dois é
melhor mas o glutamato e urbano no qual
tive outro não tem funcionários tantas
mazelas científica é um a 15 depois
deste processo de queda está o japonês
que consegue descobrir e uma está
presente em vários em vários alimentos e
eu estávamos ganhando mais de sangue é
que se quer um desses momentos tem um
nome se juntarem se combinarem uns com
os outros
o seu gordo mammy fica é implementado e
o seguro é diferente de soma em esparago
fazer compreender quem pronto não é à
toa por exemplo nós vemos os vitorianos
é comer espaguete com molho de tomate
cogumelos e primeiro tenho mais gastos
de prisão por cima
só quem isto tem uma intensidade de
sabor e os pratos pois tem uma mim e é
isso que nós tentamos procurar
presenciar as pessoas para que elas
consigam ter experiências instante bom
o senhor se os perguntado se vocês gosto
mais de dez alunos ou 12 anos
eu acho que muitos vão dizer que nós não
exclusivos e não fazer mal escolhidos ao
vermelho
mas nós somos mais gulosos pelos estados
e nós também sabemos disso e portanto
não vamos esquecer os clubes mas vamos
arranjar maneiras de fazer é usar a
mesma técnica que usamos para pegar um
país a mesma forma diferente
els cozinharem em waco que nós estamos a
fazer agora é não ser em ajuda escritas
e moderno com estas ferramentas
eu consigo exatamente a mesma coisa
quando você tem em casa um país
mergulhado num meio coso temos a
vantagem do real você é um bom condutor
do calor conseguimos que pega ponto à
volta da nossa iguaria seja cunha
da mesma forma mas desta forma eu não
tenho perda de sabor
existem três formas de cozinhar em
formas de forma mais genérica uma forma
de concentração e outra da extração e
concentração são os grelhados e os
avançados concentramos senhor não apenas
depois temos de extração e extracel é
quando nós temos um país 15 no mesmo
país vizinho há sempre trocas e olhem
que o mercosul e portanto a perda de
semana e nós temos pressa essa
consciência
ok e portanto através da técnica survey
e waco nós conseguimos ter o meia coso a
volta do nosso alimento
conseguimos cozinhar e coisas da mesma
técnica sem o senhor volta mas
conseguimos garantir que não haja trocas
e ordens como aí portanto nós
encontramos a fazer cruzeiros
nós estamos a fazer presentes em várias
respostas do pinhal
nós que vivemos no natal novamente nunca
aparece na mesa da cozinha mas mal seus
cozinhados em waco não vai perder o
sabor
campeão e isso vai ganhar nenhum técnico
ter prometido tem que ter mesmo é mas
nós conseguimos conservada não seguiria
dentro do que o livro não tem os toca
ceops como aí ok nós deixamos recolhidos
nós encontramos reduzidos nós confiamos
que fazer assim potenciar o senhor ao
tratamento o que nós temos muito o que
aproveitar o fato de gostar muito dos
estados por causa das ligações manhã
assim o francês era loucura estudou e
pela organização das proteínas dão um
sabor também gozo nós nossos
procuradores que nós podemos dar esta
imagem
olhando para a imagem do país equilíbrio
nós somos mais gulosos por esse tipo de
coisa
portanto essas novas ferramentas que nós
enquanto cozinheiros temos para
conseguir de nervos que nos sonhos não
conseguir vender mulheres especiais e
competir com os assados domingo em casa
da sogra ou o fantasma paulo onça do
metal
a apresentação é um caso esta se for um
caso é perceber é nós gastamos mais uma
porção cada ingrata
nós temos muitos condenados hoje as
pessoas têm muitos problemas de lesão e
vêm muitos chefs de cozinhá eles têm nos
ajudado muito
nós temos respeitado mas o nosso o nosso
trabalho é tentar algumas preocupações
destas nos fazem em casa é melhor a mão
horas e horas a fazer ano
portanto ninguém está na cozinha perder
tanto tempo para não não quer deixar de
vender uma emoção em criar uma emoção em
cada um dos clientes
bom me resta desejar um bom natal não
esqueça que vou pegar o metal
o piloto da casa também tem nada